j'aimerais bien savoir non pas si la
Corse va être indépendante mais quand
elle va être indépendante et quand elle
va recouvrer la maîtrise de son devenir
jean-guide à lamonie nous a rejoint
bonsoir bonsoir merci en tous les cas
d'être chez tout le monde en parle vous
êtes rare dans les talkshow donc on
apprécie d'autant plus votre présence
ici ce soir c'est vrai que c'est pas
tellement dans notre façon de
communiquer compte tenu c'est vrai de la
situation que nous avons dans Lille qui
est assez difficile et assez étendu il y
a souvent des choses des drames qui se
produisent et encore récemment c'est la
raison pour laquelle ça ne se prête pas
tellement à la rigolade c'est des choses
comme elles sont vous avez 41 ans vous
êtes le benjamin de l'Assemblée Corse et
vous êtes pourtant malgré votre jeune
âge le chef de fil de la coalition
nationaliste Corsica Nacion quand je
vous ai demandé de venir dans cette
émission vous avez hésité et au début je
comprenais mal vos réticences et puis un
jour j'ai fini par comprendre
qu'effectivement vous n'êtes pas un
homme politique comme
un homme du RPR ou du Parti socialiste
vous êtes un rebelle en lutte contre la
France d'une certaine façon vous êtes
dans la situation de quelqu'un à
l'époque de la guerre d'Algérie du FLN
je crois que c'est excessif vous savez
n'avons pas la prétention de nous
comparer à ce genre de mouvement qui
était mouvement important qui ont laissé
dans l'histoire et les traces
extraordinaire nous nous sommes
modestement un mouvement qui essaye de
maintenir le philistorique du
nationalisme corps qui a pu être rompu
pendant des siècles de résistance et
puis parfois aussi de calme parce qu'il
y a eu aussi des périodes plus cales
vous craignez pour votre sécurité pas
vraiment non je crois que vous savez
quand on a un engagement politique de la
nature de celui que nous avons je suis
l'un des responsables de ce mouvement et
bien je crois qu'on assume ses
responsabilités et on ne pense pas
tellement à ce genre de choses cet été
vous avez quand même reçu un colis piégé
j'ai reçu un colis piégé effectivement
que j'ai ouvert ce qui est plus grave en
présence de ma compagne qui
effectivement d'après ce que m'a dit le
démineur était susceptible de faire de
provoquer de gros dégâts en tout cas
vous savez qui voulait envoyer je n'en
ai pas la moindre idée par contre si
vous affaire enseignement à ce sujet ça
pourrait m'intéresser
alors on va parler un petit peu de vous
de votre vie au début du siècle
précédent vos grands-parents quitté
l'accord c'est à cause de la misère
insulaire ils se sont expatriés
outre-mer et votre père a vu le jour au
Maroc où il rencontrera sa son épouse
votre mère Elisabeth qui est d'origine
espagnole tout à fait oui donc votre
père était instituteur mais en 1956
quand le Maroc est devenu indépendant il
est reparti encore une fois il est parti
dans le Maine-et-Loire il a fait la
guerre d'Algérie
et puis 15 jours après votre naissance
il est retourné dans son pays dans le
pays
alors en 68 vos parents adhèrent au
mouvement des Frères siméonie et vous et
votre frère vous êtes de toutes les
réunions de votre plus jeune âge et en
64 quand il y a l'affaire d'Aleria il y
a eu des gendarmes tués le ministre de
l'Intérieur Michel Poniatowski envoyé
des blindés je ne savais pas des blindés
à Bastia et à 15 ans vous avez cette
image devant vous c'est-à-dire que vous
voyez les rues de votre ville
occupées par des Blancs des Français
c'est ça peut-être qui a été le
déclencheur de votre de votre engagement
contribué c'est vrai qu'il y a une
période de forte tension à lire il y a
une tension qui a été dû à des forces
qui ont été mises en oeuvre
disproportionnées par rapport à ceux qui
au fond on était au départ que nous
contestation je dirais relativement bon
enfant à la cave à lire et là on a eu
effectivement on a eu des moyens qui ont
été mis en œuvre il y a eu ce drame il y
a eu ces gendarmes il y a eu et puis il
y a eu encore l'année de Bastia il y a
eu encore un mort c'est vrai que à 15
ans ça marque ça marque je crois bon
d'accord ça n'est pas le Liban c'est
clair mais il y a eu un certain nombre
de drames qui se sont échelonnés jusqu'à
nos jours c'est vrai alors là vous
commencez à militer vous grimper peu à
peu tous les échelons et vous
apparaissez réellement sur la scène
nationale dans le cortège des
négociateurs du processus de Matignon la
loi qui a été votée cette semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale française elle
vous va cette loi pas vraiment disons
que dans la réforme qui a été prévu il y
a deux phases donc il y a cette première
phase qui correspond à la loi qui a été
votée qui est une femme une phase de
faible niveau et puis il y a surtout la
phase 2004 qui devrait permettre de
changer les choses encore c'est avec ce
qui nécessite une révision
constitutionnelle le processus de
Matignon pour vous c'est quelque chose
d'inexorable la Corse sera indépendante
dans cinq ans dans 10 ans ou au
contraire c'était une parenthèse avant
le retour de la droite aux affaires la
Corse sera indépendante j'en suis
persuadé cela dit ce aujourd'hui c'est
un compromis historique qui ne va pas
mener à l'indépendance le processus de
Matignon ça n'est pas l'indépendance de
la course c'est une avancée
institutionnelle qui a été demandé par
une majorité massive des élus de
l'Assemblée de Corse 44 élus sur 51 donc
c'est je dirais l'expression de la
démocratie encore c'est un compromis
historique ou les nationalistes ne
retrouve pas toute leur indications et
en particulier pas celle de
l'indépendance mais en même temps c'est
un moyen de faire en sorte que la paix
s'installe à notre pays et qu'on puisse
les uns et les autres continuent à
défendre notre notre idée dans un cadre
apaisé et dans le cadre de relation
constructives entre la Corse et Paris
vous avez pas l'impression de vous faire
rouler dans la farine des fois par le
gouvernement français mais il nous
arrive de nous poser la question c'est
vrai que nous avons beaucoup payé par le
passé pour savoir qu'il faut être
extrêmement méfiant quand on discute
avec un gouvernement qu'il soit français
ou autre et qui a des moyens
considérables et puis qui fait souvent
preuve des cynisme donc c'est vrai que
nous avons cette idée en tête que nous
pouvons nous faire rouler dans farine
comme vous dites mais nous essayons
d'éviter quand même vous citez cette
phrase de chimie qui est le fondateur du
Parti communiste indochinois par amour
de la paix nous avons fait des
concessions
mais plus nous en faisons plus les
colonialistes empiète sur nos droits
est-ce que vous avez pas ce sentiment là
en ce moment je crois que là aussi il
faut pas superposer des situations qui
sont très différentes l'accord ce n'est
pas l'Indochine elle n'est pas l'Algérie
mais effectivement on retrouve un
certain nombre de réflexes de la part de
l'appareil d'État qui à un moment donné
dans une négociation de vouloir un petit
peu jouer sur plusieurs tableaux
d'avancer à certains nombres de
revendications qui sont acceptables et
puis ensuite de reculer de faire des
promesses de régner sa parole on a vu
cela encore récemment mais je crois que
il faut laisser sa chance à la paix il
faut laisser sa chance à ce processus
aujourd'hui il est interrompu de tout
évidence nous avons provoqué en quelque
sorte une crise en suspendant notre
soutien un processus parce
qu'effectivement il y avait des
reniements de la parole donnée mais nous
l'avons fait nous avons provoqué cette
crise pour remettre le processus sur les
rails parce que nous pensons que le
problème Corse ne pourra pas trouver de
solution ni de notre côté en gagnant la
guerre contre la France ça serait
ridicule de penser cela ni du côté de la
France en passant régler le problème en
mettant tous les nationalistes en prison
alors jean-guité à lamanie vous publiez
chez DSL Ramsay un livre qui s'appelle
ce que nous sommes avec une préface
d'Albert mimi alors voilà première
question
issue de la lecture de ce livre
vous êtes français ou pas
ce qui me concerne je ne me sens pas
français mais je respecte tout à fait le
sentiment des nombreux corps c'est qui
se sentent français je crois que à un
moment donné et bien les corps se diront
s'ils veulent aller à l'indépendance
cela dit le fait de dire je ne suis pas
Français ou ça n'est pas du tout pour
moi une marque de rupture de
d'agressivité ou encore moins de mépris
parce que mes prix est un sentiment qui
m'est assez étranger c'est simplement le
fait de dire nous sommes un pays nous ne
sommes pas deux départements français
nous avons notre territoire nous avons
notre histoire quand vous êtes à Paris
comme là vous vous sentez à l'étranger
mais je me sens jamais vraiment à
l'étranger moi quand je me promène en
Europe qu'il s'agisse de Paris ou de
Barcelone ou qu'il s'agisse de Rome
où est Bruxelles je crois qu'il y a une
identité européenne nous sommes aussi
engagés dans la construction de l'Europe
c'est même notre voie vers
l'indépendance l'Europe nous nous
pensons que avec un mouvement en faveur
du d'un pouvoir local et un mouvement en
faveur un pouvoir européen la tutelle
française qui l'espace politique
intermédiaire à vocation progressivement
à disparaître le peuple corse c'est quoi
c'est avoir du sang encore c'est avoir
des parents corps c'est à ce moment-là
vous n'êtes pas vraiment Corse parce que
votre mère est d'origine espagnole ou si
être né encore tout simplement est-ce
que c'est le droit du sang ou le droit
du sol le peuple corse est un peuple qui
est composé de Corse d'origine et de
corps d'adoption l'accord ça toujours
fabriqué des Corses à toutes les époques
et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des brassages
au cours de notre histoire donc
aujourd'hui la notion de communauté des
stars a été réaffirmée par l'ensemble
des nationalistes l'ensemble il n'y a
aucun groupe nationaliste et pourtant
Dieu sait qu'il y a des formations ici
aucun groupe nationalistes qui est du
peuple corse une approche ethnique ça
n'existe pas
il y a des gens qui s'appellent Dupont
il y a des familles qui sont d'origine
sans doute britannique et depuis
plusieurs siècles mais ça n'est pas une
question de non ça n'est pas ça ni une
question de gêne alors la nation corse
elle a une terre elle a une langue elle
a une culture elle a une histoire un
drapeau à l'anime
comme la Bretagne finalement
je crois que encore une fois je crois
que c'est pas l'Algérie ça n'est pas non
plus la Bretagne je crois qu'il faut
tenir compte à la fois de notre histoire
du caractère récent je dirais de
l'annexion par la France puisque 250 ans
- 250 ans c'est pas très ancien il faut
tenir compte aussi de la volonté d'une
partie des corps et de l'évolution de
l'opinion Corse aussi parce que l'idée
indépendante et minoritaire aujourd'hui
je vous le conseille la question mais
elle progresse je dirais régulièrement
alors pour vous pour vous l'accord
finalement c'est une nation qui a été
vaincue et occupée par un oppresseur
pour nous pour l'histoire je crois que
l'accord c'est effectivement été annexé
par les armes ce qui avait fait dire
acheté et annexé par les armes ce qui
fait dire à Rousseau à Voltaire un
certain nombre de choses Voltaire qui a
qui s'était élevé contre le fait que la
Corse a été achetée et qui a dit très
clairement est-ce que des hommes ont le
droit d'acheter d'autres hommes Rousseau
qui a parlé d'une expédition de corps
cynique et ridicule qui est contre toute
humanité donc ça c'est l'histoire cela
dit nous ne tenons pas les Français
d'aujourd'hui pour responsables vous
aimez pas beaucoup de Napoléon qui est
pourtant le plus célèbre des Corses
c'est un peu un collabo pour vous
Napoléon c'est à dire qu'il a collaboré
avec la France d'une certaine façon bon
là aussi peut-être c'est anachronisme de
dire collabo ça correspond à autre chose
je crois que Napoléon à notre avis à eu
tort de changer de camp enfin en tout
cas peut-être pas pour ça il était pas
au liste jusqu'à 20 ans et après il a
trahi son pays c'était violemment anti
français alors que les nationalistes
d'aujourd'hui n'ont jamais été
anti-français Napoléon était
anti-français et il a dit très
clairement Adrienne un de ses camarades
je ferai tout le mal pourrait appeler
français je crois que de savoir si c'est
un cadeau que l'accord ça fait la France
c'est très discutable je pense que si on
met le débit et l'actif le passif c'est
vrai que c'est on parle moins de Paoli
qui est plutôt votre corps préféré je
dirais fondateur au 18e siècle d'une
république démocratique qui a inspiré la
démocratie américaine c'est des choses
qu'on sait peu parce que vous êtes
victime faut bien le dire de la
propagande française dans les livres
d'histoire disons que l'histoire
d'accord ça n'a pas été enseigné en
réalité c'est avec beaucoup de peine
qu'aujourd'hui les professionnels
cherchent à faire rentrer donc cette
histoire de la Corse dans dans
l'éducation des enfants c'est important
parce que la Corse a apporté aussi sa
contribution à l'Europe des Lumières en
créant la première démocratie
constitutionnelle de l'histoire de
l'humanité personne ne le sait à une
époque où c'est vrai la plupart des pays
européens était sous le jour d'un roi de
droit divin donc une démocratie avec
effectivement le droit de vote pour les
femmes depuis le 14e siècle du reste les
femmes avaient le droit de voter depuis
quand encore depuis le 14e siècle en
France 1945
c'est-à-dire que vous l'assumez d'une
certaine façon oui je crois qu'il faut
dire les choses clairement nous le
refusons de condamner la violence oui
parce que nous ne voulons pas confondre
la cause de la maladie et ses symptômes
je pense que aujourd'hui de répéter
comme par incantation il faut que la
violence disparaisse il faut qu'on ait
la violence etc ça n'est pas s'attaquer
aux causes de la maladie nous ne voulons
effectivement que la violence
disparaître et nous faisons tout ce qui
est en notre possibilité pour que ça
soit le cas et ce qu'il faut à notre
avis pour cela c'est changer les
conditions qui ont fait être la violence
politique quand on vous dit que la
violence c'est inacceptable dans une
démocratie vous dites oui mais la Corse
ne vit pas dans une démocratie la
démocratie Corse reste à construire vous
savez il y a eu pendant des décennies et
des décennies une fraude électorale
massive on a pardonné Paris à pardonner
aux élus planistes toutes leurs
turpitude en matière de fraude
électorale de d'évolution des marchés
publics scandaleuses de détournement de
données publiques et ils ont été absous
moyennant une allégeance totale
quotidienne à Paris et c'est vrai que ça
pose un problème de démocratie quand le
scrutin est faussé de manière aussi
évidente et puis il y a autre chose il y
a aussi le fait que les élus corps se
mêlent dans strictement aucun point sur
le devenir de l'accord selon ce que l'on
voit par exemple l'Assemblée de Corse
prendre des positions unanimes comme par
exemple sur l'enseignement obligatoire
de la langue corse et qu'à Paris on dit
mais c'est tout à fait inacceptable dire
qu'une décision unanime des
représentants de l'Assemblée de Corse ne
signifient rien pour Paris est-ce que
c'est vraiment un système démocratique
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'amnistie pour les assassins du préfet
Erignac j'ai dit et j'ai répété que la
loi d'amnistie devait concerner
l'ensemble des faits politiques des
faits politiques et manifestement il
s'agit là ce que on vous parlez on peut
avoir une opinion sur la question en ce
qui concerne l'organisation dont je fais
partie à la condamné à l'époque cet
attentat cela dit il y a des faits
politiques et c'est fait politiques
doivent tous être pris en compte
j’évoquerai par exemple le cas du préfet
Bonnet de toute évidence il ne s'agit
pas d'un délinquant de
dans notre esprit il est tout à fait
évident qu'il doit bénéficier
je citais même un exemple qui me touche
encore plus personnellement vous parliez
du colis piégé il est évident que la
personne qui m'a envoyé ce colis piégé
il a fait pour des raisons politiques
la conclusion est claire ça va amener
cette personne mais évidemment mais
évidemment mais c'est logique je crois
que la loi d'amnastique partout ailleurs
dans le monde quand il y a une solution
politique et bien après tout le monde ce
que vous envisagez c'est un grand
passage d'éponge général comme les deux
sens des accords d'évier en une certaine
façon si vous voulez vous pouvez dire
qu'au moment nous accorder viande comme
comme en ce moment en Irlande où on
libère un certain nombre de détenus qui
ont été condamnés il y a seulement trois
ans pour des actes très graves pour des
homicides donc imaginons le problème
résolu on va faire de la politique
fiction la Corse donc est indépendante
elle est rattachée directement à
Bruxelles sans passer par Paris
maintenir un lien institutionnel avec
Paris ça serait vraiment facteur de
lourdeur de complexité et ça
serait pas conciliable avec une bonne
gestion on est très bien alors l'accord
c'est indépendante elle est reliée à
Bruxelles il y a un président de la
République Corse mais pourquoi pas je
crois que sur les courses que choisiront
et qui choisiront demain
ça serait vous le président de la
République bien sûr certainement pas
parce que vous savez candidats y compris
dans l'hypothèse d'une évolution
institutionnelle
je sais oui c'était le cousin germain de
mon grand-père qui est sénateur
[Musique]
si les choses tournaient mal
et si vous aviez besoin d'avoir recours
aux armes après une répression de
l'armée française est-ce que vous seriez
prêt à tuer des Français bon travail à
moi c'est pas de prendre des armes c'est
pas des tirer sur les gens c'est pas des
tuer des gens de la mort c'est pas mon
métier moi mon travail essaie de
rechercher avec les autres élus de la
Corse et vois et moyen pour que plus
jamais une idée de drame encore et c'est
déjà une tâche très difficile à laquelle
nous essayons des ateliers et nous
sommes un certain nombre à le faire
grâce à Dieu je suis loin d'être seul
est-ce que vous comprendriez que dans la
rue des corps tirent sur les Français
vous savez je crois que il y a des gens
qui tirent sur des gens partout dans le
monde et je crois qu'il ne sert à rien
de dire si c'est bien si c'est pas bien
il faut que ça s'arrête et je pense
qu'il y a des gens et des mouvements qui
partout dans le monde cherchent à
trouver la voie de la paix la voix de la
paix elle est très difficile la paix ça
n'est pas la tranquillité doit pas être
confondu avec la tranquillité la paix ça
va être la paix d'un peuple debout sur
sa terre maître de son destin dans le
respect des autres entretenant des
relations fraternelles avec les autres
et c'est ce que nous nous proposons de
faire pour notre part on rallume
[Musique]
Jean-Guy était à l'avenir on va vous
faire un petit tardiville
[Musique]
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment
je suis en train de me demander quel va
être votre question suivante
quand avez-vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois à l'occasion d'un deuil là-bas vous
avez l'occasion souvent oui mais on ne
pleure c'est vrai peut-être pas
tous les deux ils ne sont pas égaux dans
la vie d'un homme
que pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous
non je crois que
peut dire que je suis fainéant c'est
vrai et j'aime pas tellement travailler
mais en revanche on peut dire quelque
chose de positif sur moi c'est que je
travaille quand même beaucoup donc vous
voyez j'ai du Mérite parce que ceux qui
aiment travailler donc
travailler vous avez raison quel est
l'insulte qui vous a fait le plus mal
je reçois de temps en temps des lettres
d'insultes ça ça m'arrive notamment
l'Assemblée de Corse beaucoup venant de
la quasi-totalité venant de France mais
d'ailleurs je reçois aussi beaucoup de
lettres sympathiques venant de France
mais alors au début ça me faisait
quelque chose et puis il y avait un mot
qui revenait une expression qui revenait
souvent c'est de course et
beaucoup commencé leur lettre à
de cours vous prenez les sous des
Français vous voulez pas être français
etc vous êtes là danseuse de la France
vous de Corse c'est
quelque chose qui me fait toujours et
bon j'avoue que maintenant j'ai fait
plus tellement attention je les mets au
panier quelle est la question dont vous
aimeriez avoir la réponse
j'aimerais bien savoir
non pas si la Corse va être indépendante
mais quand elle va être indépendante et
quand elle va recouvrer la maîtrise de
son de son devenir j'aimerais savoir
quand parce que j'aimerais bien le voir
mais si je le vois pas ça fait rien vous
avez menti pendant cette interview non
je n'ai pas menti et
m'est arrivé de mentir dans la vie
quotidienne ça m'est arrivé je suis pas
ça mais je crois que en matière
politique le mensonge est dévastateur
dévastateur moi il m'arrive de pas
répondre aux questions notamment avec
les journalistes je leur dis écoutez je
vais pas répondre
là je l'ignore là vous savez là par
contre non seulement je n'y réponds pas
mais j'aurais du mal à vous répondre
mais il y a des questions que je réponds
pas des parfois il y a certains de vos
confrères qui me disent mais c'est la
langue de bois j'ai dit oui oui c'est la
langue de bois parce que je veux pas
répondre à votre question c'est vrai ça
ça m'arrive mais je ne mens pas je ne
mens pas parce que vous savez encore il
y a une expression qui est pas mal qui
dit abuji à Shanka d'ailleurs le
mensonge est boiteux et on le voit de
loin ça apporte le discrédit et le
discrédit sur une personne ça n'a pas
d'importance sûrement mais le discrédit
sur un mouvement politique c'est grave
je crois alors je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse me prendre un défaut de ce point
de vue là j'essaie de dire pareil à tout
le monde
[Musique]
ce que nous sommes chez DSL rentrer là
monsieur
est-ce que vous pensez que la Corse va
être indépendante un jour vous savez
Poiré
demandait la dépendance pour quelqu'un
qui habitait dans la rue de la Forêt
mamie Laforêt et jusqu'à présent ça n'a
pas abouti
vous en pensez quoi Emmanuel vous du
discours de Jean-Guy de lamonite c'est
position
c'est beaucoup trop complexe pour que je
puisse en dire quoi que ce soit
c'est non pas que ça ne m'intéresse pas
parce que j'y passe une certaine partie
de mon temps c'est une île qui me fait
battre le coeur et je vais vous dire un
truc absolument horrible je me sens chez
moi je suis désolé mais sans doute vous
vous sentez autant chez autant chez vous
que je me sens chez moi ici vous
comprenez leur démarche vous comprenez
qui de toute façon j'ai je sais pas
comment vous dire je regarde cet homme
parlé c'était évident qu'ils m'ont pas
assez évident qu'il est dans un combat
qui le rend je sais pas honnête s'il y a
quelque chose qui me touche en tout cas
il y a quelque chose qui qui fait que
que voilà que j'ai un homme intègre en
face de moi à côté de moi et que je peux
pas être insensible à ça ouais du truc
c'est que le régionalisme c'est un truc
que je ne comprends pas parce que je ne
comprends même pas le sentiment
d'appartenance à la France ou un pays le
truc de patrie c'est un truc je ne
comprends pas ce que ça veut dire par
contre il y a une chose que je crois que
je comprends c'est que la colonisation
c'est vraiment ça le truc et que ça fait
partie de leur histoire et que et que
donc ça doit correspondre à cette
histoire mais j'y connais rien
moi j'ai du mal moi déjà on parle de
nationalisme à la base ça va pas quoi
c'est un mot qui me plaît vraiment
c'est quand même les valeurs culturelles
on s'en fout quoi Marina non mais c'est
vrai Marina elle est italienne moi je
suis pas douche je suis puis on se
mélange et puis tout va bien et moi il y
a oui n'importe quoi
s'il y a eu des problèmes il y a eu EDF
qui est venu et tout enfin je sais pas
j'ai vu des trucs à la télé parce qu'il
y avait des problèmes de il fallait
remettre des poteaux électriques et tout
et là c'est marrant et nationaliste ils
disent pas non non mais les cedf rester
nous on va le faire on va retirer les
cagoule et on va remonter les poteaux
lorsque il y a eu des catastrophes
identiques notamment dans le sud-ouest
de la France il y a quelques années j'ai
personnellement déposé une émotion à
l'Assemblée de Corse pour que
l'Assemblée de Corse envoie des fonds
pour aider les populations françaises
sinistrées et cela au titre la
solidarité européenne mais tout
simplement au titre de la solidarité
humaine
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
que les gens puissent à un moment donné
eux-mêmes pour avoir quelque chose à
partager avec leurs voisins je crois que
si nous sommes tous identiques et bien
nous allons perdre quelque chose
certainement mais nous allons faire
perdre aussi quelque chose à ce que l'on
rencontre en nous si nous voulons être
corps c'est avoir notre identité c'est
aussi pour avoir quelque chose à
partager avec des gens qui sont
différents et c'est très important si on
arrive à un monde où tout le monde est
identique à un monde uniformisé où on
parle la même langue où
si on part tous anglais qui ça peut
faire c'est pas super grave il y a juste
plus grave mais je crois que si nous
parlons tous anglais si nous habillons
tous de la même manière si nous mangeons
tous la même chose et bien le monde sera
beaucoup plus triste c'est mon point de
vue mais je vous oblige pas à le
partager c'est clair moi je viens du
Nord on a notre culture en bois de la
bière et on mais on dit pas demain je
veux être je veux que je me le Nord soit
un pays et que l'Isle soit la capitale
idiot oui comme un autre
de
baisser le niveau
pas durer voilà c'est réussi merci
merci
Jean-Luc à la mamie d'avoir accepté de
participer à un talk show et surtout
celui-ci à bientôt et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu